[Music]
okay so did you guys know that an ice
cream man
um once existed
who used to taste ice cream for dryers
and he did so good at his job they
ensured his taste buds for up to one
million dollars with an insurance
company dude that's a true thing it's a
true thing it's a fact his name is john
harrison i remember when i was watching
uh a pretty classic episode of um mr
rogers oh i was gonna say mom and like
would you [ __ ] mom or dad was a
classic character that was a pretty
classic yeah that's up for the stream
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's up for streaming through the
conversation do you guys remember mr
rogers and the [ __ ] train would come
out and then they will take you to a
different portal yeah
make-believe yeah and then they had
different um stuff away educational like
themes right and one was like different
jobs yeah and one was an ice cream
tester that was a [ __ ] job and all
the kids saw that [ __ ] and i remember we
all talked about it at school like did
you know that there's a job where you
could just test ice cream all day and
everyone's like oh my god it's so cool
and for me i was like ooh why did i have
to be so [ __ ] lactose and he'd be
like well daniel do you know what
lactose is that's pretty good
i love the way you took a sweater i
wonder if it sucks to be an ice cream
tester the way that being a video game
tester ended up sucking oh yeah
no but like like i knew people that did
that and it was like not what it they
probably insured his taste buds for a
million but they paid him 15 [ __ ] you
know a thousand a year
probably all you do is eat ice cream all
the time you think eat ice cream so good
guess what i'm [ __ ] chilly i have to
wear a coat day
i get cold all the time
they spit it out dude he has to eat it
in the freezer
[Laughter]
what if he's the funny thing like nick
too and he like hates all the flavors
who made this you should die not my
favorite rocky road what the [ __ ] is a
toffee nut
what's a neapolitan bro just call it
[ __ ] strawberry chocolate and vanilla
just split the flavors separately you
gotta get fancy bro we all got it
already like you should die
it should die we don't need them all
together
just call it segregation ice cream
exactly uh so yeah no this starts in
1880 when harrison's great grandfather
opened two ice cream parlors in new york
and sometime later his grandfather
started the first dairy co-op in
tennessee
after that his father owned an
atlanta-based dairy factory and his
uncle owned a memphis-based ice cream
factory and then he was an assistant
taster for his uncle that's how he like
got in the game that sounds telephony
he's an apprentice assistant uncle he
goes let me show you the ropes are
tasted son right so and and that's what
happened basically so in 1980 he joined
dreyers which was then known as ed's in
the eastern u.s like carl's jr and
hardy's right
and and he was the the company's head
tester that's where he retired in 2010 i
wonder how many testers do they got they
do have they do have quite a few but he
um he tasted but but really swallowed
yep a few hundred million gallons of ice
cream he pointed at you anything
i don't swallow much they have to go
through so much they go up or they'd be
[ __ ] jabba
dude
they'd be like the gluttony and [ __ ]
um that's happening i don't trust like
[ __ ] prestigious cooks or chefs that
like aren't [ __ ] fat you know what
i'm talking about oh yeah like they
gotta be fat yeah yeah well no it's not
that they gotta be obviously there's a
bunch of like very very fit amazing
cooks but when they're fat i'm like yeah
probably i'm gonna [ __ ] eat this
i was watching this ramen documentary
and then this dude he's a ramen chef
right but he's so [ __ ] into ramen
that he eats it every day so after he's
done uh cooking he goes out and he goes
to his competitors ramen shops but he
doesn't go to one he'll have a whole
bowl he'll [ __ ] drink the suit and
then he'll walk to the next one and
he'll hit a [ __ ] another bowl and
this guy is skinny and everyone's just
trying their [ __ ]
just to see what he's passionate about
it yeah so it's r d like well he's he's
researching the competition seeing
what's out there but he just loves ramen
anytime you get to [ __ ] eat food and
call it r d that's just so sick yeah
that's good that's a fun time so [ __ ]
sick it's how i feel when i get to like
do a business right off of like a meal
that i'm having with my wife and i'm
like we talked about our [ __ ]
business today
it was a business meeting we talked
about our business that's kind of like
the thing that's happening yeah i want
to try this for the cool kids
continuity is ruined your chair
definitely says joe on it i mean joe's
more corporate i don't know if he can
handle it because we're more blue collar
hello his says steve iceman
but you're sitting next to steve wait
where am i
oh oh
no his says steve i have the tif chair
oh [ __ ]
congrats
that's the host chair uh so according to
harrison it's all in the taste buds
right when did you guys start doing this
so he we're pretty cool man he claims
that he invented he co-invented cookies
and cream and could immediately tell the
difference between 12
versus 11.5 percent fat in a product wow
tastes better do you think he would know
how to do the pepsi challenge what's the
pepsi challenge pepsi versus coke they
would like give you a blind taste test
challenge right they would have two
dixie cups full of pepsi and coke do you
think you could and they'd like taste
one which one's better
i feel like but then they only aired the
one that was uh pepsi
anytime somebody chose coke they just
deleted it from the commercial one of
the one of the things one of the uh very
few brand deals i ever did for the tubes
was for pepsi and i remember being so
bummed because i love coke me too yeah i
was like oh i [ __ ] hate you pepsi you
suck i used to be a coke man but then
bart turned me i mean a pepsi man but
barf turned me into coke is too sweet
yeah pepsi does this weird thing i was
originally a coke man and then i went to
pepsi when i was younger and then when i
started traveling coke shits on pepsi
around the world [ __ ] with it like
destroys it well why is that mexican
coke is actually better than you mexican
coke is like [ __ ] i'm observant i see
you what's what's your defense because
we think your [ __ ] taste buds are wow
he drinks his surge i like pepsi as a
packaged cola i like coke as a fountain
drink
i like i like your style dude i don't
know
i like your stuff i'll take i'll take a
can of coke still yeah yeah but you know
what you each their own i like ryan as a
punched face
and an anal dash
so um he says all in the taste buds
right so um he was so valuable to dryers
that they had they paid to insure his
taste buds for a million dollars
because they thought that what he did
was such a value added their product
that it was like worth it i wonder what
he does like like quality control to
make sure that the batch of ice cream is
consistent yeah
and why is there a breyers and a dryers
because it's always confusing [ __ ]
similar man i don't know this is jk news
we don't know those answers because i
need to know i need to can you can you
can you call it
thank you okay
why is there
that's a [ __ ] good question
why is there briars and you think
they're like [ __ ] best friends that
had to break up
yeah i mean because both of them
don't mean ice cream it's someone's name
i got you ready the root of the
confusion dates back to 1850 uh 1953
when edie's grand ice cream was changed
to dryers grand ice cream seeking to
eliminate the confusion that this
created dreyer's changed his name back
to the home market of briars
from dreyer's grand i'm more confused
what the [ __ ] wait so there's the same
company but they produce two different
times you google it and then it's a game
of mousetrap and you're like oh no you
know why because it's just some guy who
wrote the article he probably doesn't
[ __ ] know wait dryers and briars are
the same company yeah i thought it was
two different ways why the [ __ ] did they
do that time is that like [ __ ] honda
and acura no they're two totally
different companies it says and this one
too oh my god i'm so confused now too
that's not even is that like is that
like nike and jordan yeah let's just say
that i think it's like lexus and toyota
right now alexis is like very clearly
like the luxury line of the toyota yes
so which one's the better one dryers are
briars lexus and toyota are the same
it says it says jordan and nike are the
same
shut the [ __ ] up with your wet ass hat
happening what's happening
this hat still soaked oh no do you have
a favorite ice cream company am i
allowed to do a shameless plug
yeah don't tell me ken just coming out
with ice cream no don't tell me cage has
go ahead if you shop at gelsons
go get some clemon
k-l-i-m-o-n it's no milk backwards no no
milk no dairy no difference what what is
in there well how is that it's just a
dairy free ice cream that tastes like
regular ice cream and they have my
favorite is the [ __ ] uh orange bang
flavored one that's what i need though
dude
ask for steve rollups
because we're limited time only but we
are emerging
get a steve roloff yeah fruit punch
fruit punch is my favorite there's fruit
pies from the screenshots it just sounds
already like a [ __ ] good setup
[ __ ] roll-ups dude don't sleep on it
i haven't i have like a limited time
partnership with trader joe's is it like
what is that like a fruit leather
i hope
i'm gonna try it
i'm gonna try it
i have a limited time partnership i'm
gonna try it people what's happening
it's happening wait what's what's your
connection with clemon clemone that's my
buddy's ice cream that's like killing it
right now but it's like really good but
it's good for people that are lactose
intolerant yeah yeah so i actually so
because i went to this house to do a
taste he's like dude you gotta taste
these before and they're they're
actually in walmart's uh nationwide
right now they just came out and they're
in gelsen's now but she's like i did a
table this is the last time i did a
taste test so he like gave me like
cherry bomb which is pretty much like
cherry infused like vanilla stuff give
me like an orange bang flavor type thing
i don't remember what's called a bunch
of other random stuff like double
chocolate whatever
i [ __ ] did you guys like orange
julius or orange yeah
orange creamsicle stuff that's what i'm
saying that but like that flavor but
it's like no dairy i'm like because i
i'm not i'm like kind of like lactose in
that like i'll still suffer it but i'll
be farting all day yeah what i'm saying
i'm painful lactose so like my stomach
will well that's what i'm saying so now
now when i'm eating like a dairy-free
ice cream that tastes the same i'm like
[ __ ] yeah but it tastes the same it
really does it does because dude we cut
some quarters of steep roll-ups
and i think we lost away
you know doesn't taste like fruit at all
tastes like dick
i'm listening to your story and i'm like
we got some corners
and i think i lost the vision of what my
product was supposed to be what is the
packaging what's the packaging look like
how do we know
i [ __ ] had
but yeah i think i just think that we
lost our way and i think that we let the
consumerism like take over you sound
like gustavus from ratatouille right now
dude
that's you guys heard it here first
trader joe's steve rollups it was just
supposed to be a great product
[Music]
[Music]
you